happy day seven of vlogmas if you guys
are new here hi I'm Justine and I've
been giving away gifts all week and
today we are giving away an Xbox series
S I am so excited about this I've been
playing so much Call of Duty that I'm
actually kind of struggling to see right
now because I've been playing so much
that my eyes are basically falling out
of my head so I look forward to you
getting an Xbox series s and maybe you
can uh spot up with us on Warzone you
might not want to because I'm usually
the one that they want to get rid of and
for some bonus entries go follow Xbox on
Twitter for more information on how to
enter check out ijustine.com vlogmas see
you there